foreign  [Music]  knows how it starts  but when the fear begins when the  paranoia takes over  it makes people do terrible things  good morning as you can see some of you  have chosen to stay home today given  what's been happening  there's something going around some  scary internet character that tells you  to kill people it made this kid stab his  own mother there's a lot of people  freaking out about it nobody knows what  it actually is  you saw the Grim Cutty yeah like in my  house well what is it  [Music]  to be getting calls about it all night  how are we supposed to protect our  family  but when I try to tell them what I saw  it just makes it more hysterical  can we start over  we can just sit down and I'll talk it  out together  I'm just trying to protecting  [Music]